bonjour et bienvenue en ce vendredi
matin on va faire un point carte pour
vous expliquer ce qui se passe non pas
en Ukraine comme on en a ce qu'on a fait
souvent mais à Taïwan pour savoir tout
ce qui se passe sur cette île les
tensions qui animent cette île avec la
Chine et aussi tous les alliés
potentiels de la région et pour en
parler je suis bien sûr avec Alexis
fercha bonjour Alexis bonjour Vincent
journaliste adjoint au pôle Actu du
Figaro on va parler forcément de Taïwan
et on va tout de suite d'abord parler
parce que on entend beaucoup parler
Taiwan parce qu'il y a un parallèle
adressé avec ce qui se passe en Ukraine
le parallèle adressé il vient
naturellement c'est que la guerre en
Ukraine ce qui nous a frappé depuis
depuis un an c'est c'est la la
l'intensité de cette guerre là la haute
intensité
tous les chiffres sont
son pharamineux et là ce que l'on
pressant en fait avec Taïwan c'est
l'hypothèse qui paraît pas incroyable du
tout d'une guerre qui a priori aurait
des dimensions aussi grandes voire plus
élevée pour une raison simple c'est que
finalement la guerre avec la Russie la
Russie c'est une très grande puissance
militaire qui a montré toutes ses
limites mais ça reste une puissance
militaire c'est une grande puissance
nucléaire mais c'est pas non plus un
géant économique là on parle d'un
conflit qui mettrait aux prises
directement ou indirectement évidemment
Taïwan mais surtout les États-Unis et la
Chine c'est elle est deux plus grandes
puissances mondiales
avec une puissance la Chine qui qui
prétend enfin qui qui envisage la
possibilité de venir la première
puissance mondiale devant les États-Unis
donc on voit bien que les enjeux sont
colossaux et donc il y a quelque chose
de vertigineux et de ça fait maintenant
pas mal d'années que le
la situation se tente de plus en plus on
va voir qu'il y a des évolutions
historiques et c'est ce parallèle avec
la guerre en Ukraine qui d'une certaine
manière nous nous fait peur est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui a deviendrait si
si voilà le l'étincelle était allumé
parce que la grande différence parce
qu'on en reparlera mais la guerre en
Ukraine
les alliés des
Ukrainiens n'interviennent pas
directement en
Ukraine ce qui se passe et c'est une
guerre terrestre et donc les alliés
peuvent approvisionner d'un point de vue
logistique l'Ukraine point la ligne
c'est tout et donc la Russie n'est pas
en prise avec les États-Unis là on parle
d'une potentielle guerre avec une île
qui situe à 100 km de la de la Chine
continentale et donc si les Américains
interviennent il n'y a qu'une
possibilité c'est une intervention
directe on verrait des bateaux
américains
taper des cibles chinoises etc alors
vous commencez à nous rejoindre je vois
dans le chat du vous n'hésitez pas bien
sûr tout au long du live à poser vos
questions nous on y répond on va quand
même d'abord rappeler Taïwan ou c'est
cette petite île qu'on voit là encerclé
en jaune au large de la Chine au large
de la Chine là et là on voit pas
forcément représente pas forcément bien
les distances mais c'est très proche de
la Chine il y a sangle il y a un détroit
donc c'est pas là la Chine continentale
et Taïwan et donc des trois il fait 100
km de large c'est à la fois rien qu'en
garde sur une carte
mais ça d'énormes implications
militaires puisque dès lors qu'on
envisage une guerre à Taïwan c'est une
guerre amphibie c'est-à-dire avec le
milieu
maire mercole c'est il faut envisager un
débarquement et en fait un corridor de
de 100 km de large de de mer représente
un obstacle absolument considérable pour
les Taïwanais et je pense que c'est
vraiment la première chose qui faut dire
c'est on regarde la carte on se dit mais
les Taïwanais non absolument aucune
chance Taïwan c'est 36000 kilomètres
carrés quasiment 20 fois moins grand que
l'Ukraine pour reprendre un parallèle
c'est 20 millions d'habitants donc c'est
la moitié des Ukrainiens et en face 2
ils ont un pays gigantesque de plus de 9
millions de kilomètres carrés avec un
milliard et demi de chinois et encore
une fois c'est la première puissance
enfin la deuxième puissance économique
au monde et même la première en termes
de PIB en parité de pouvoir d'achat donc
on regarde ça on a un peu envie de c'est
un peu David on est dans Astérix Obélix
et un village d'irréductible et on se
dit c'est pas possible mais le caractère
amphibite cette guerre fait que on en
reparlera
c'est en réalité extrêmement risqué pour
la Chine dans le scénario où il y a une
intervention américaine alors on va
alors je vois Ariane qui me dit dommage
qu'il y qu'il y a un sous-titrage ou
qu'il n'y ait pas sous-titrage alors le
sous-titrage sur Youtube vous pouvez le
désactiver en tout cas si c'est ça dont
vous dont vous parlez mais non ce titre
pas en direct bien évidemment alors ce
ce Taiwan on disait j'ai un peu
d'histoire voilà c'est ça un peu
d'histoire pourquoi est-ce que la Chine
s'intéresse autant à Taïwan alors ce qui
est très intéressant dans la dans
l'argumentaire chinois et ça veut pas
que pour Taïwan ça vaut aussi pour la
zone au sud-ouest de Taïwan oui qui est
la mère de shiny régionale avec tout un
tas de deal on en reparlera mais
l'argumentaire des chinois c'est
toujours de dire c'est historiquement la
Chine qui en fait il revendique des
droits historiques c'est-à-dire des
droits représentés sur un sur un passé
ce qui est intéressant dans le cas de de
Taïwan quand on regarde un peu
rapidement on a fait un article il y a
maintenant un an de plus d'un an c'était
quand il y avait eu la visite
de Nancy Pelosi qui était alors là
président de la Chambre des
représentants américains qui étaient
venus et ça avait créé un grosse
polémique un scandale diplomatique donc
on avait fait ce papier pour montrer que
finalement Taïwan malgré cette proximité
géographique n'a pas toujours été
chinoise en réalité c'était une île il y
a eu une vie un peu pendant des siècles
assez reclus sur elle-même parce que et
en fait les chinois sont
intervenus au 17e siècle à la fin du 17e
siècle ils ont que le nisé Taïwan et là
c'était que colonisé jusqu'en 1895 et là
c'est passé sous la coupe des japonais
c'est passé sous la coupe des Japonais
jusqu'en 1945 là je veux vraiment je
voudrais sa grandrée l'histoire de
Taïwan il y a toute une partie donc on
va dire avec des
les populations toktones de Taïwan puis
à la colonisation chinoise au XIXe c'est
compliqué simplifie mais à la fin il y a
la colonisation japonaise
1895-1945 et après il y a ces grandes
dates de 1949 là il faut avoir la guerre
civile chinoise en tête
1927-1949 avec d'un côté
les communistes et donc là il y a
évidemment la figure de mode setum et de
l'autre il y avait les nationalistes qui
étaient soutenues par les par les
États-Unis avec Jean kitecheck et un
parti le coming Tang qui existe toujours
on reparlera parce qu'ils ont changé de
positionnement politique et donc
militairement en
1949 les nationalistes perdent des noms
de Shanghai est obligé de se rapatrier
de se réfugier dans l'île de dans l'île
de Taïwan et c'est là que naît un état
taïwanais qui d'ailleurs au début est un
allié des Occidentaux mais avant j'ai
pas une démocratie et ça restera une
dictature jusqu'à la
en tout cas un régime très autoritaire
jusqu'à la fin des années 80 l'état
d'urgence du rage jusqu'au 1991 bref à
ce moment là il va y avoir une
modernisation oui surtout une
démocratisation de Taiwan qui va qui va
devenir oui un des grands régimes des
démocratiques en Asie avec la Corée du
Sud et le Japon et donc on en est là à
une différence près c'est que du coup en
1949 les grands pays occidentaux ont
fait le choix de reconnaître Taïwan
comme la Chine et donc c'est la
République de Chine et puis enfin si
elle a République populaire de Chine
qui n'est pas reconnu par les par les
Occidentaux mais ça va changer enfin on
sait que la France va être le premier
pays à reconnaître
la Chine communiste et en disant c'est
la seule Chine donc
juste montrer cette carte assez
rapidement c'est justement cette carte
là c'est les États qui reconnaissent
aujourd'hui il y en a plus
[Musique]
donc l'ONU représente tous les tous les
pays il y avait Taïwan absolument le
diabète Taïwan et en fait Taïwan était
reconnu comme étant la Chine ça a
complètement changé maintenant et voyez
tout ce qui est le la date qu'il faut
avoir en tête donc c'est 1979 c'est
assez date c'était une grande année 70
et puis il y avait aussi le la politique
on va dire que le les États-Unis se sont
rapprochés de la Chine avec le grand
voyage
américain apk et on reconnut la
République populaire de Chine comme
l'unique Chine et depuis le principe qui
veut c'est le principe d'une seule Chine
mais en même temps le soutien
occidental à Taïwan et toujours là mais
il y a ce que les Américains appellent
l'ambiguïté stratégique donc c'est le
concept de la politique étrangère
américaine vis-à-vis de Taïwan et on
sait qu'il y a un an enfin un peu plus
d'un an maintenant s'il y a un nom en
mai en mai 2022 Joe Biden avait dit
qu'il protégerait Taïwan au cas en cas
d'agression militaire chinoise et ça
avait fait un peu polémique et les
Chinois avaient été très mécontents et
d'ailleurs les États-Unis étaient
revenus dessus parce que là Joe Biden
avait
remis en cause en tout cas verbalement
il y avait donné l'impression de
remettre en cause verbalement ce
principe de d'ambiguïté stratégique qui
est finalement le seul moyen
de faire vivre le concept de Chine
unique sans complètement abonnés
abandonné Taïwan alors on a pas mal on a
pas mal de questions dans le chat dont
on va répondre forcément Chris Kross
rock'n for Dream qui nous parle alors
pour le pour la partie histoire
d'ailleurs je remercie pour ce
historique forcément je vous renvoie à
cet article vide de la présente c'est
parti qui a été écrit du coup l'an
dernier lit la telle toujours été
chinoise pour avoir vraiment tous les
détails je vais on va donner la réponse
c'est non voilà il a aidé donc la
réponse est non puisque en plus vous y
avez répondu tout à l'heure Kriss Kross
qui me demande Taïwan a-t-elle vraiment
les moyens de résister
à une guerre de la Chine alors là je
vous conseille un autre article
l'article de Nicolas Barotte et de
Sébastien Faletti sur les scénarios
militaires à propos de Taïwan et là si
vous voulez ça fait des années des
années des années que les occidentaux
font des wargames et on ne dit pas en
français des jeux de guerre enfin
l'origine c'était les
Allemands c'est une manière de modéliser
la guerre ça sert absolument pas prédire
ce qui va se passer mais c'est à
s'entraîner c'est à montrer ça sert à
s'entraîner à me modéliser pour voir
ensuite quelle variable intervenir etc
et donc là il faut tout de suite partir
du principe qu'il y a deux scénarios qui
sont complètement différents et pour
lesquels les réponses sont claires le
premier scénario c'est la Chine attaque
Taïwan et Taïwan se retrouve seul face à
la Chine et là il y a
aucun aucun scénario aucun modèle dans
lequel Taïwan peut résister c'est
littéralement impossible donc là la
Chine finit par l'emporter militairement
par occuper l'île et en gros c'est une
affaire de un mois on va rentrer dans
les détails mais c'est pour avoir les
les grandes lignes directrices et puis
le deuxième scénario c'est un scénario
où les États-Unis seraient
interviendrait aux côtés de Taïwan et
encore une fois on parle pas d'une
intervention comme auprès de l'Ukraine
qui n'avait
là on parle d'une intervention directe
et bien là aussi il y a eu énormément de
wargames depuis 20 ans et donc il n'y a
aucun scénario
dans lequel les Chinois finissent
vraiment par l'emporter
là je vous conseille un autre papier de
synthèse qui a été écrit par le colonel
Michel Goya sur son alors c'est pas sur
le Figaro c'est sur son blog la voix de
l'épée
et qui est une bonne synthèse de tout ce
qui a été fait depuis 20 ans et alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'en fait il
y a quand même plusieurs leçons à
retenir c'est que la Chine dans ce cas
là ne gagne jamais mais si on regarde
sur 20 ans elle perd de moins en moins
c'est à dire que le le il y a un
rééquilibrage progressif mais pas encore
atteint
en faveur de en faveur de Pékin donc sur
le temps long sur le talon ensuite il y
a différentes encore une fois c'est pas
pour prédire l'avenir donc il y a
plusieurs hypothèses dont le scénario le
pire pour chinois peut pour la Chine en
deux semaines c'est plié
récapitule je résume mais en gros la
flotte écoulée etc et en deux semaines
Taïwan a gagné dans le scénario le
meilleur pour la Chine il y a une
situation d'enlisement c'est-à-dire que
malgré tout
les Chinois arrivent à débarquer à
Taïwan a créé une tête de pont à
avoir un train logistique du continent
jusqu'à Taïwan et simplement là il y a
un point d'équilibre qui est atteint
rapidement dans la guerre parce que
Taïwan résiste en face les Américains
harcèlent les événements les Chinois des
trois Taïwan peuvent eux-mêmes envoyer
des
du matériel voir des hommes à Taïwan
parce que eux aussi ont des groupes
amphibie pour créer une ligne logistique
et là on arrive à une sorte de statu quo
de statu quo avec Taïwan
2 voilà c'est vraiment de manière à
grands trait ce que l'on peut dire
militairement mais après ça vaut le coup
de rentrer dans les détails parce qu'il
y a plein d'enjeux qui ne se voient pas
quand on regarde une carte on a du mal à
imaginer que moi les Taïwanais
pourraient résister pourrait
effectivement résister Chris Kross il
est évident que Taïwan a du matériel
américain bien supérieur en termes
technologique
alors là faut toujours se méfier je
pense que notre leçon de la guerre en
Ukraine
il faut il faut se méfier
ce qui est très intéressant c'est que ça
ça avait été théorisé par un amiral
de Taïwan qui avait appelé ça à la
stratégie du hérisson
c'est elle parle d'elle-même
c'est-à-dire que l'objectif pour Taïwan
c'est de faire le hérisson de
et d'attendre d'attendre que la
cavalerie arrive c'est dans les western
américain voilà c'est exactement ça sauf
que c'est pas de la cavalerie c'est
c'est la marine c'est des avions
et donc cette stratégie du
hérisson l'idée c'est pas d'avoir
plein de missiles qui iraient très loin
plein d'avions plein de bateaux plein de
c'est au contraire de de faire Joseph
orotin appelle de la techno guérilla au
contraire tout misé sur la flexibilité
sur la mobilité sur des armements légers
les Chinois auront mal à frapper parce
que si par exemple la défense de Taïwan
repose par exemple sur une flotte de
chasseurs multiro le très nombreux etc
et bien l'attaque chinoise de Taïwan va
commencer par des frappes de missiles
balistique et de croisière chinois qui
vont à priori détruire énormément
d'infrastructures lourdes donc tous ces
équipements lourds il faut il faut s'en
méfier et donc oui après Taïwan reçoit
des armements chinois il y a certaines
armements qui pourront faire la
différence notamment les missiles anti
navire les Américains ont proposé ont
promis des Harpoon qui est le grand
missile anti navire américain une portée
de 2300 km donc est largement suffisant
dans le cas présent
mais sinon alors il y a quelques je
reviens David contre Goliath mais on
reparlera de la flotte chinoise et
aujourd'hui sur le papier
absolument hégémonique en Asie c'est des
chiffres vertigineux en face Taïwan sur
le papier c'est absolument ridicule ils
ont quatre sous-marins dont deux ils
sont des sous-marins américains date de
1943 et 1944 ils ont été modernisés mais
c'est quand même des sous-marins qui
date de la dernière guerre et ils ont
quatre destroyés regardez les destroyer
vous avez l'impression d'être dans un
film de la guerre froide et pour cause
c'est des destroyés Américains qui
datent de 1960
en face la Chine à 50 destroyer
mais ça s'arrête pas là parce qu'il y a
cette guérilla cette capacité finalement
de combat asymétrique et on l'a vu nous
le son de la guerre en Ukraine
l'armée
l'Ukraine ne dispose plus de marine au
sens la plus de bâtiment de guerre ce
qu'elle a encore quelques vedettes qu'en
fait ce sont des éléments extrêmement
légers et des drones sous-marins mais
sinon sur le papier la marine de guerus
en mer Noire était complètement
juridique et ça n'empêche pas qu'il y a
une dimension navale de la guerre en
Ukraine et que l'Ukraine continue à
exercer une pression sur la sur la
flotte russe grâce à seulement des
missiles grâce à des missiles à des
drones à des opérations commando etc etc
de la symétrique alors j'ai une question
de dénappes qui va nous faire sortir un
peu de la du côté militaire qui me dit
j'ai bien compris la Chine parce qu'ils
veulent une seule Chine et c'est un peu
ce qu'on disait aussi avec Hong Kong à
une époque oui
on voit par exemple le c'est intéressant
parce que le le
Hong Kong en 2020 il y a eu des
manifestations pour démocratiques et qui
avait été
[Musique]
maté très très très vigoureusement et
violemment par par la Chine
Hong Kong c'était encore un autre
système c'était un
état de système
que que
90 mais là où c'est différent c'est que
là il y a une sorte d'état de fait c'est
que c'est que Hong Kong fait partie
de la Chine
Taïwan
on ne le dit pas officiellement mais
Taïwan a absolument tous les attributs
objectifs
d'un État souverain la seule chose
qu'elle n'a pas c'est la reconnaissance
internationale mais même là-dessus il y
a une ambiguïté stratégique qui est
intéressante on dit par exemple il y a
pas de d'ambassadeur de Taïwan aux
États-Unis ou en France et inversement
il y a pas de d'ambassadeur occidentaux
à Taïwan mais en fait il y a des il y a
des instituts il y a un institut
taïwanais et américaine à Taïwan et ces
gens là ont exactement les mêmes rôles
piano donc si vous voulez c'est vraiment
une question de l'ambiguïté mais on peut
pas complètement même pas du tout
comparer avec Hong Kong on n'est pas
dans la même dans la même dans la même
situation et j'ai complètement oublié
pourquoi on parlait de parce qu'on nous
demandait justement si la Chine était si
enfin si la Chine veut récupérer Taïwan
parce qu'ils veulent qu'il n'y ait que
il y a un nationalisme
chinois
et il y a une chose qui est claire qu'on
lit les déclarations chinois c'est que
les chinois
ne feront aucune concession ils l'ont
encore 10 ce matin
exactement dans ces termes c'était le
ministre des Affaires étrangères ils ne
feront jamais de concession sur Taïwan
et donc ils ont une forme d'ailleurs de
ils disent à la fin vous l'aurez la
guerre
si on ne trouve pas une solution
pacifique de réintégration
et ensuite de rééducation un mot employé
par l'ambassadeur de Chinon en France
bien cette guerre toute manière elle est
inévitable donc préparez-vous la
question c'est le timing la date
finale obsèle les Chinois de extrêmement
nombreux c'est 2049 parce que ça va être
le centenaire de la République populaire
de Chine mais mais un des stratège
militaire
ont toujours envisagé une guerre plutôt
à la fin des années 2020 voyez entre
2027 2030 pour différentes raisons mais
il y a aussi une raison il y a ce
rattrapage militaire de la Chine fait
que pour arriver au niveau des
États-Unis les Chinois parlent de
d'armée de classement deal c'est une
manière de dire atteindre l'appareil
avec les États-Unis ça il leur faut des
années même s'ils ont à toute vitesse
sur plein d'aspect et puis l'autre chose
que j'ai que j'ai déjà oublié ah oui
c'est ça il y a le rattrapage
militaire et puis il y a le facteur
notamment démographique la Chine est un
pays qui vieillit et on l'a vu par
exemple cette année
il y a quelques semaines officielle
quelques jours officiellement l'un des
passés devant la Chine en termes de
population
et donc c'est un enjeu démographique
énorme c'est que la population chinoise
va se contracter énormément dans les
dans les années les décennies à venir et
puis aussi les chinois sont souvent ont
un enfant et donc on envoie pendant une
famille on envoie un enfant à la guerre
tout à fait pareil cet aspect
psychologique là est important c'est pas
pareil de perdre un enfant qu'on en a un
seul que quand c'est une famille mais
nombreuse donc il y a la question
ensuite le nationalisme chinois il est
là il y a la question c'est du
consentement à la guerre et donc les
Chinois de ce point de vue là n'ont pas
forcément
intérêt à attendre éternellement et donc
ce qu'on entend la petite musique qu'on
entend
depuis un an c'est l'hypothèse d'une
intervention chinoise qui pourrait de
intervenir plutôt
en 2024 2025 il y a des hauts gradés
américains qu'on en parlait
officiellement mystère
de la Défense américaine
qu'elle met ça mais les mots ont été
prononcés alors après on peut dire oui
mais c'est extrêmement risqué les
Chinois n'ont pas intérêt à le faire et
puis plus ils attendent lui ils sont
forts par rapport à Taïwan militairement
oui mais parfois on fait des choses
extrêmement risquées et c'est une c'est
une leçon de la guerre en Ukraine
encore une fois là la guerre en Ukraine
c'est pareil on avait dit au début que
les
chars russes
et je me souviens on en avait parlé très
rapidement au début en se disant mais
attention les Russes on voyait 200000
hommes ont attaquer un pays de de 600
000 kilomètres carrés on habitants par
les Occidentaux
et en réalité extrêmement
risqué et là de la même manière dans le
scénario d'intervention américaine de
soutien américain c'est extrêmement
risqué pour ne pas dire bien pour les
pour la Chine puisque je le répète il y
a aucun wargame dans lequel la Chine
l'emporte dans le scénario
du soutien américain direct oui alors on
pourrait être de détroit de Taïwan tout
à l'heure alors il y a aussi comprendre
quelque chose et ça on le sait via ce
qui se passe en Ukraine c'est que pour
on peut attaquer mais ensuite il faut
arriver à créer une chaîne logistique et
faire une une chaîne logistique dans un
détroit ça paraît aussi extrêmement
compliqué on a vu en Ukraine au niveau
de au niveau de Carson les Russes ont
été obligés de reculer parce que là ça
va encore être le cas les militaires
appellent ça des coupures humides c'est
c'est les endroits où il y a un
ralentissement de la manœuvre
justement à cause d'éléments d'éléments
naturels et
bras de mer et donc le diable déjà est
en Ukraine et une coupure humide
importante mais mais faut se dire que
c'est une
le maître moyen alors ça peut monter
jusqu'à 10 20 km c'est un endroit mais
enfin en moyenne on parle en kilomètres
là c'est 100 km donc c'est
pour le dire vite on peut pas mettre un
pont flottant
traverse la rivière et est passé avec
des directement avec des véhicules en
fibi avec des des petits canaux pour
faire passer les hommes il faut des
bâtiments lourds
amphibie
et à la fois des bâtiments
amphibie classique et puis des portes
hélicoptères
et ça on a vu des choses très
impressionnantes en plus chinois en
quelques années seulement ils ont mis en
service trois portes hélicoptères 40 000
tonnes de déplacement c'est à peu près
deux fois la taille de nos de nos portes
hélicoptères Mistral
donc sur le papier c'est extrêmement
impressionnant ils ont aussi huit
énormes
amphibie mais qui ont pas de plateforme
hélicoptère au dessus donc dans l'absolu
c'est c'est très important mais et c'est
là où on voit les limites naturelles
c'est que quand vous calculez à peu près
le nombre d'hommes ça permet de
transporter en un voyage jusqu'à jusqu'à
Taïwan on parle allez de 30 000 40 000
hommes au maximum avec toutes les la
trentaine de bâtiments de taille plus
modeste alors ensuite vous pouvez aussi
passer par les airs
des parachutistes le jour le plus long
le film se débarquement de Normandie où
vous pouvez dire il y a 100 km donc vous
pouvez imaginer aussi d'une composante
d'attaque avec des hélicoptères mais le
problème c'est que dans les airs vous
faites pas passer d'une matériel lourd
ou très peu donc là vous faites passer
de de
la feutrine légère et donc tout repose
finalement sur quelques énormes bateaux
des portiques
pour faire passer quelques dizaines de
milliers d'hommes pour établir
une tête de pont mais là ça suffit pas
ensuite il faut faire débarquer
il faut qu'il défense pour tenir la tête
de pont et ensuite permettre des
ravitaillements de l'île et là il faut
pas quelques dizaines de milliers de
soldats il faut des centaines de
milliers de soldats c'est pour ça qu'il
y a une deuxième étape c'est l'emploi de
grand ferry civiles qui serait détournés
de leur
usage pour emmener cette deuxième vague
ces centaines de milliers d'hommes et
ensuite vous imaginez ravitailler des
dizaines de milliers d'hommes il faut il
faut la nourriture il faut des munitions
il faut du pétrole etc etc donc c'est un
enfer logistique et donc pour ça il faut
avoir une maîtrise des mères il faut
avoir une maîtrise désert et ça ça n'a
rien d'évident alors évidemment la
flotte taïwanaise il est probable
qu'elle sera détruite assez rapidement
la fois la flotte navale et la flotte
aérienne mais comme je disais tout à
l'heure il y a des moyens d'attaque
asymétriques
des des
missiles Harpoon qui seraient sur des
installés sur des batteries côtières il
y a évidemment les mines et puis après
il y a toute la partie américaine c'est
à dire que les Américains sont capables
d'envoyer plusieurs groupes aéronaval et
puis on a qu'un ça c'est à peu près 80
euros 9
c'est 5000 hommes c'est 100000 tonnes
d'acier
c'est chose de d'ABS absolument
que le sale et là dans tous les
scénarios si vous voulez
l'aviation américaine notamment finirait
qu'on ne le pas
sur la Chine qui notamment parce que
parce que la première étape c'est les
chinois ne voient pas leurs avions ils
envoient des missiles des missiles
balistiques et
là est-ce que les au bout d'un moment le
stock chinois ne serait pas inépuisable
et donc les américains comptent sur deux
outils militaires principaux
d'abord les missiles
ont inavis depuis des avions alors soit
vous partez avec des bombardiers depuis
des basses terrestres par exemple à Guam
on parlera toujours tout à l'heure de
l'aspect géopolitique mais donc il y a
vous partez avec des bombardiers avec
des missiles qui s'appelle les jasmes er
une endurance assez assez grande
soit des chasseurs plus classiques
d'écoles des porte-avions et là vous
pouvez vous apprendre le projet
davantage des côtes ça c'est la première
arme sur laquelle les américains
comptent beaucoup et la deuxième c'est
les sous-marins et là les les Américains
ont un avantage absolument considérable
parce qu'ils ont des sous-marins
nucléaires d'attaque
alors ils ont quelques problèmes parce
qu'ils ont une énorme flotte ils ont du
mal à l'entretenir un rythme suffisant
mais sur cet aspect là le retard des
Chinois est considérable ils ont 9
sous-marins nucléaires d'attaque en
réalité il y en a trois qui sont hantées
diluviens ils ont 6 qui sont modernes
mais modernes au sens qui ont été
fabriqués récemment mais en réalité en
termes de technologie de de furtivité de
discrétion etc n'a rien à voir avec les
Los Angeles
notamment américain et donc là il y a
une vraie asymétrie en faveur des
Américains et dans tous les wargames les
sous-mains américains font des
c'est un carnage pour la marine chinoise
or je vous l'ai dit finalement le
l'invasion de Taïwan repose sur quelques
grands bâtiments
finalement et donc si la Chine perd 1 2
peut porter c'est pour elle
un désastre absolu pareil on est le
porte-avions chinois les Chinois vont
très très vite
mais malgré tout ils n'ont que deux et
demi aujourd'hui parce qu'ils en ont
deux qui sont anciens et vraiment pas au
niveau des américains ils ont un nouveau
où là il y a de quoi être impressionné
ils sont passés à des catapultes
électromagnétiques on fait un saut
technologique après sinon mais ils en
ont qu'un qui est pas encore en service
et avoir un outil c'est bien mais
ensuite il faut savoir l'utiliser et
former une une
compétence aéronavale mais ça prend des
des années voire en réalité l'expérience
de l'histoire c'est peut-être des
dizaines d'années et c'est une matière
dans laquelle il y a très peu de de
champion il y a évidemment les
américains c'est la grande puissance
la socratique puis à la France puis un
tout petit niveau un public et notre qui
nous demande est-ce que la Chine soit
susceptible d'y accéder d'accepter une
solution pacifiste
je suis pas devin donc je oui alors on
rappelle
c'est que la détermination chinoise et
le nationalisme chinois
sont total
il y a pas tellement de doute
et la solution pacifique on voit pas
très bien
quelle
forme elle pourrait prendre parce qu'il
y a le nationalisme chinois et en face
il y a la détermination détermination
des taïwanais
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas une majorité de
taïwanais qui veulent revendiquer la
nationale
l'indépendance de Taïwan formellement
parce que ça bien que ça déclencherait
majorité sont d'accord avec
avec la l'ambiguïté qui existe
actuellement
en revanche l'écrasante majorité
sont pour une autonomie qui est celle
aujourd'hui d'un état après sa varie par
exemple en 2016 la situation c'est
notamment venimie en 2016 parce que une
nouvelle présidente il venait du parti
plutôt indépendantiste
c'est indépendantiste avec des
guillemets parce que
elle-même n'a jamais déclaré
formellement l'indépendance de Taïwan
mais disons le parti le plus autonomiste
et ce qui est étonnant c'est que le
parti historiquement nationaliste qui
était celui de Shanghai check le
commington les rôles se sont inversés
aujourd'hui c'est le parti
qui est
celui qui est favorable un dialogue avec
la Chine donc une sorte d'inversion
historique et ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est que le comming Tang
a plutôt le vent en poupe dans les
sondages donc il pourrait y avoir un
nouveau
basculement
mais il y a trop de variations
on a une autre jour qui nous demande sur
les sur les sur les îles chinoises il y
a d'autres îles entre Taïwan oui et on
voit bien voilà c'est alors justement
alors on vous les montre là c'est c'est
celle-ci aussi sont importantes oui oui
c'est là on peut envisager les
différents scénarios alors il y a des
îles qui sont vraiment vous voyez là où
il y a tout de suite
de la côte chinoise bon la militairement
on comprend bien que
l'enjeu militaire c'était plié pour les
Taïwanais s'il est ça c'est les îles qui
appartient à Taïwan absolument d'accord
à vérifier et justement en fait il y
avait il y a d'autres villes qui sont
plus proches de Taïwan on voit pas très
bien mais mais
à l'ouest de Taïwan
je veux pas dire sur le nom
on les voit sur cette carte là voilà et
donc si vous voulez il y a plusieurs
scénarios
intermédiaires avant une grande invasion
de Taïwan il y a notamment la reprise
des
îles côtières ensuite il y a la reprise
des îles pescadoresques qui sont déjà
plus proches de la de la Chine de Taïwan
pardon et puis après il y a le scénario
qu'on évoque très souvent que le quel
scénario du blocus oui parce qu'un
scénario aussi extrêmement crédible
ce qui imaginez que Taïwan serait
littéralement coupé du monde avec un
blocus naval
et aérien
oui puisque là dans ce cas là
les Alliés autant intervenir sur une
entrée en guerre direct de la Chine
autant sur un blocus
mais il y a plein de manières indirecte
de l'avenir j'en parlais avec un marin
qui faisait remarqué un navire chinois
certains cas c'est très difficile
d'attribuer oui l'origine de la de
l'attaque évidemment si un bateau de
surface vient de surface qui attaque
on le voit là on peut pas on peut pas le
cacher mais
c'est un sous-marin par exemple c'est
beaucoup plus discret donc là encore il
y a toute une un éventail
et dans l'escalade
c'est pas un bouton ON et un bouton off
les
Occidentaux aussi ont une capacité de de
jouer sur une forme d'ambiguïté dans
leur dans leur soutien à
éloigne mais alors là il y a un autre
enjeu qu'un enjeu économique oui alors
je vais
carte on va le montrer on voit des
petites puces ces petites puces ça
représente des semi-conducteurs alors
déjà on peut expliquer peut-être que
c'est des des
conducteurs
pour tout ce qui est électronique pour
tout ce qui est électronique et
toute l'industrie pour toute la vie
économique d'aujourd'hui et
ce qu'il y a c'est que Taïwan est le
grand producteur
mondial de
de plus et de semi-conducteur et on voit
les chiffres qui sont impressionnants
c'est quasiment un peu moins de deux
tiers ils viennent de Taïwan et ensuite
on voit l'isolement aujourd'hui de la
Chine parce que finalement les
États-Unis et l'Europe c'est quand même
on va dire 10% chacun
la Corée du Sud qu'un autre grand allié
des États-Unis c'est quand même 16%.
mais la Chine c'est propre
si la Chine se retrouve privée de
semi-conducteur mais c'est une
catastrophe économique et industrielle
pour pour piquer donc évidemment il y a
cet enjeu là alors la Chine rattrape son
retard elle essaye je crois d'ailleurs
qu'elle y parvient à Séville en termes
de dynamique mais elle part de 3% donc
et donc là encore c'est un argument qui
rationnellement
plaide en faveur d'une intervention
ne serait pas demain pour la Chine là la
Chine a tout intérêt à le papier à
garder et puis de ça et puis en plus on
imagine mal la Chine ici de de six
attaques et ouais il faudrait raser les
villes
complètement détruire tout ce
qui fait ça
alors mais après inversement
si les occidentaux étaient privés de
l'industrie chinoise
serait aussi enfin verserait des
périodes extrêmement difficile et
économiquement donc c'est jamais noir ou
blanc en tout cas ce chiffre là de 3% et
il est quand même très impressionnant et
les Chinois l'ont en tête oui
effectivement on a d'ailleurs alors on
n'a pas d'image mais de de
deimping le
chef d'étoiles le chef d'État chinois
qui en a reparlé de Taïwan en disant que
c'était un objectif absolument c'est un
objectif absolu pour la Chine
oui ça je sens on peut le dire et
d'ailleurs les Chinois même
l'ont dit
ils l'ont dit
on finira la parle par la voix c'est
quel que soit les moyens qu'on utilisera
voilà sur le prix les moyens militaires
et ça ils l'ont exprimé formellement
il y a peut-être une autre carte qu'on
peut montrer qu'il y a de la région qui
permettrait d'avoir une approche
peut-être plus globale pour comprendre
quelle est la politique de la Chine
justement c'est celle-ci il me semble
donc effectivement cette carte avec la
Chine est aussi tous les autres pays qui
sont plutôt des alliés de les États-Unis
absolument et il y a un phénomène et là
encore faire un petit parallèle avec les
gars en Ukraine
on a du mal à
s'imaginer mais les Chinois se sentent
eux aussi
encerclé par les par les États-Unis et
là il y a un enjeu géographique il faut
avoir à l'esprit est-ce que les chinois
appellent
la première rangée de Deal alors c'est
celle qui le c'est celle qui soit
[Musique]
il y a trois frontières maritimes dans
le discours chinois il y a cette
première chaîne d'île
mais qui finalement décrit une zone très
étroite un peu moins moins étroite au
niveau de la mer de Chine méridionale
mais surtout c'est une zone enclavée on
va dire c'est c'est une zone de défense
côtière ou littorale on parle de 100 km
c'est rien du tout et après il y a une
il y a une deuxième chaîne d'île qu'on
voit qui part du Japon
qui va
jusqu'à
la base et surtout en passant par goam
qui est là la grande base américaine
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur
entre Guam et la coach chinoise il y a
3000 km d'accord et donc là ça c'est
l'enjeu région al pour la Chine et donc
au début la Chine s'était dit notre
objectif c'est de contrôler le toute la
zone d'être souverain sur la même
dominant dans dans la première chaîne
d'île ensuite on a un deuxième objectif
historique
et d'être dominant
dont la deuxième chaîne d'île et c'est
pour ça que les ils ont commencé à
construire une marine de haute-garres de
une marine de haute mer
et ensuite ils ont une troisième chaîne
deal mais je ne dis l'abstraite monsieur
abstraite qui est l'océan mondial et
aujourd'hui dans son clairement pas là
toute leur marine aujourd'hui leur
aviation leur
missile à longue portée sont vraiment
pensés pour ce deuxième cette deuxième
chaîne d'île parce que
comme on dit tout à l'heure la guerre de
Taïwan ne sera pas une guerre littorale
de la première chaîne d'île en partie
mais il y aura la dimension de
l'intervention américaine qui elle a une
un enjeu journal évident puisque
le Japon les États-Unis ont une
énormément de base dans le monde soldats
de navire et d'avion
au Japon
ils en ont en Corée du Sud et ils ont
non aux Philippines traité de défense
entre les deux pays et récemment
il y a
depuis quelques semaines ça a été
annoncé il y aura quatre bases
américaines
que les Américains pour utiliser au nord
des Philippines oui donc en fait ça va
être assez mais extrêmement proche de
parce que le nord des Philippines c'est
ici alors
on voit aussi toutes ces
bases américaines l'enjeu pour la Chine
ça aurait été de finalement être
récupérant donc alliés toutes ces toutes
ces îles là plutôt qu'elles tombent avec
les États-Unis
oui alors le cas des Philippines est
intéressant puisque un moment je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez de ce
président extrêmement
populiste on va dire les douter
et qui avait tenté un rapprochement avec
la avec la Chine et ensuite les
Philippines ce sont retournés du côté
des États-Unis et donc en fait la Chine
a une grande politique la route de les
nouvelles routes de la soie
il y a des routes de la soie on va dire
classique par la terre
est assez stratégique en la matière ou
les pays d'Asie centrale il y a la Route
de la Soie par la mer
et on voit très bien que la mère de
Chine méridionale donc à l'ouest de
Taïwan avec les grands récifs les
îles les
rassels et des
extrêmement important
pour la navigation chinoise parce que ça
permet ensuite d'aller vers la vers la
Malaisie vers le détroit de Singapour et
ensuite de passer dans l'océan Indien en
termes de projection
aujourd'hui les Chinois veulent avoir
l'assurance d'avoir une influence et un
contrôle total mais mais une influence
dans l'océan Indien
et là-dessus c'est vraiment pas évident
pour les Chinois parce qu'il y a des
enclaves géographiques qui se voient pas
venir évidente qu'on regarde trop
rapidement
la carte la Chine a plus elle a moins
d'alliés parce qu'on pourrait penser
traditionnellement la Chine n'a pas
délite la Chine ne fait pas d'agneau
d'accord bah c'est sa politique
on peut s'interroger sur la relation qui
existe aujourd'hui entre la Chine et la
Russie entre la generation
on voit qu'il y a un grand rapprochement
entre la Chine et l'Iran avec en même
temps et paradoxalement rapprochement de
la Chine et l'Arabie Saoudite mais la la
Chine n'a pas d'agneau ne forme pas
d'alliance elle n'aime pas ça dire que
ça a beaucoup d'effets pervers de
la Chine se donne une image extrêmement
pacifiste de de pays qui n'a pas de
culture impérialiste et évidemment cette
image la Chine dresse d'elle-même on
voit très bien que c'est une image en
creux des États-Unis parce que les
États-Unis c'est les champions des
alliances a commencé par la Grande
Alliance qui est le temps et que
il est vrai que les États-Unis ont mené
énormément de guerres expéditionnelles
depuis 1945
eux récemment c'est que la plupart de
ces guerres ont été un échec et si vous
voulez cette échec ce grand échec
historique de la politique étrangère
américaine sert le discours entre
guillemets avec beaucoup de guillemets
pacifistes de la Chine comme comme il
sait aussi la Russie
et plein d'autres pays de ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le
sud global les briques ce qu'on appelait
avant les émergents mais qui sont
aujourd'hui largement largement émergés
merci merci Alexis faire chaque on a je
pense qu'on a fait le tour de cette
situation de de ce sujet vous n'hésitez
pas bien sûr vous pouvez retrouver ce
live une fois qu'il sera terminé pour si
vous avez raté le début vous pourrez le
retrouver je veux quand même vous
montrer les deux deux articles dont on a
parlé les scénarios risqués d'une
invasion chinoise écrit par Nicolas
Barotte et
Sébastien Faletti a retrouvé sur le site
du Figaro et un autre article dont on
parlait tout à l'heure visite de la
présentation
Lille a tout a-t-elle toujours été
chinoise et l'histoire n'a pas changé
depuis voilà l'histoire de jouer depuis
effectivement c'est toujours le cas et
on peut répondre que non voilà mais vous
pouvez le découvrir dans ce papier merci
une nouvelle fois Alexis merci à vous
d'avoir été très nombreux à nous suivre
et je vous dis à bientôt pour de
nouveaux live sur figuerolive